today on the matt welsh show according
to recent reports huge
droves of american families are flocking
to homeschool they're fed up with the
way the school system has responded to
the chronovirus
they're now choosing to educate their
children themselves there's good reason
to think that this shift may be
permanent
and part of a larger trend and we'll
talk about why that's a very good thing
because we cannot reclaim our culture
until we break
the public school system's stranglehold
on our children
also five headlines including the media
flipping out because bill barr allegedly
wants to arrest and try protesters with
sedition
and arrest the mayor of seattle among
other things we're supposed to hate bill
barr for this but instead i kind of want
to make him king
to be honest in our daily cancellation i
will cancel the cardinal in new jersey
who says that a christian can in good
conscience vote for joe biden
no a christian cannot all of that coming
up but first
i want to tell you about um a new
sponsor on the show i'm very excited
about
uh it's called thinker now you know it's
it's really important to read books i'm
a big believer in actually reading books
uh because we spend a lot of time just
consuming little bits of information
on the internet and you read headlines
and memes and stuff like that most of
the time
when someone says oh i've i've
researched this topic what they mean is
they've read some facebook names
you need to actually read books and but
it's hard to find the time to do that
thinker makes it a lot easier to do in
our fast-paced world it's tough to make
reading a priority at least
it used to be at thinker.org they
summarize the key ideas from new and
noteworthy
nonfiction giving you access to an
entire library of great books
in bite-sized form you can read or
listen to hundreds of titles in a matter
of minutes
from old classic like classics like dale
carnegie's how to win friends and
influence people to recent bestsellers
like
jordan peterson's 12 rules for life
that's a big one that's really popular
on thinker
thinker offers a large variety of titles
across many categories current affairs
politics business
education history relationships you can
even find titles from um
a guy named matt walsh uh the unholy
trinity
church of cowards you can find that and
ben shapiro's right side of history
uh but there are many many titles
besides that
i know the the guys who run thinker and
they're great guys and this is a great
product
i've used it myself many times i like to
use it um especially if i'm if i'm
thinking about reading a book
but i don't know if i want to commit all
the time to it i'll check it out what it
says on thinker i'll get the key ideas
and then i'll figure out okay do i want
to go buy the whole book and and really
dive into this
if you want to challenge your
preconceptions expand your horizons
become a better thinker go to
thinkor.org that's t-h-i-n-k-r-d.org to
start a free trial
download the app today let them know you
heard about them on the matt wall show
that's
thinker.org okay now a recent article
in the atlantic tells us that the
pandemic has families leaving the public
school system in droves
and embracing homeschooling and this
shift we're told may be permanent this
is from the article reading now it says
homeschooling families
which include roughly three percent of
school-aged children in the united
states in 2016
have lots of different reasons for
wanting to educate their own kids but
they're united in a common assessment
they want out of the traditional system
the question is whether covet 19 will
cause a temporary bump in homeschooling
as parents piece together their days
during the pandemic or mark a permanent
inflection point in education that
continues long after the virus has been
controlled
some families may find they want to exit
the system for good
now the data does seem to bear this out
and it's an interesting article in the
atlantic by the way and actually
friendly to homeschooling if you could
believe it a gallup poll released last
week finds that one in 10 families with
school-aged children
are now homeschooling that means the
number of homeschoolers in america has
doubled in just one year
now granted a portion of these families
may return to the public school ranks
once the lockdowns and
mass policies end if they do any time
this century
but there's reason to think that as the
atlantic says the change may be lasting
after all
these are families who have unenrolled
and severed ties from the school system
completely
and in some parts of the country the the
number of parents who've taken that step
is even more staggering texas for
example has seen a 400
increase in parents withdrawing from the
public school system which mirrors
pretty closely
uh the reported 300 increase in traffic
to
sites like homeschool.com it's an online
community for homeschoolers
so there's an intense interest in
homeschooling now the trend towards
homeschooling has been
you know given a significant shot of
adrenaline adrenaline recently but
it didn't begin with the pandemic over
the last two decades
the size of the homeschooling community
had already doubled before the lockdowns
began
what was once considered sort of a
fringe movement for christian
fundamentalists on one side
of the political divide and then hippie
granola crunchers on the other
has been increasingly embraced as a
possibility for people of all
lifestyles and ideological persuasions
what makes this
this this moment so significant is that
the lockdowns have broken the final
barrier that prevented many parents from
exploring the homeschooling route
that barrier was psychological more than
anything it was the belief that
public schools do something special
that the average parent cannot emulate
or even improve upon
it was thought even by people who are
otherwise skeptical of government
control
that parents teaching their own kids is
somehow disordered
or weird or backwards or not how it's
supposed to be
we need the school system it was thought
education
is the systems thing it's it's specialty
parents don't have the ability or the
resources to take its place
that was always a facade in fact parents
are the primary educators of a child
whether they accept that role officially
or not
they still are there is nothing the
school system does that a parent
cannot do and do better there is no role
the school system is better suited to
fill
the most natural and for the child
healthiest choice is to be taught
full-time
by parents who know them love them
understand them can meet their specific
needs
if large-scale government-controlled
education has any role it should be as a
backup a plan b
or maybe c or d not as the automatic
default option for everybody now it's
not as though the public school system
has been a rousing success up to this
point either
headlines this week tell us that um you
may have seen this young people today
have a
quote shocking lack of knowledge about
the holocaust over half of the
respondents in a recent
survey didn't know that six million jews
died in genesis
in the genocide one in ten couldn't
recall ever hearing the word holocaust
in their lives
none of this is actually shocking though
polls and surveys for years have shown
that americans have a very uh shall we
say tenuous grasp
of basic subjects like history science
civics
a survey conducted a few years ago
discovered that only about 30 percent of
americans could pass a citizenship test
less than 30 could identify the 13
original colonies or
or or you know say one thing that
benjamin franklin was famous for
almost 40 percent thought he was famous
for inventing the light bulb
another study reveals that one in five
americans can't name a branch of
government
a a survey released by the american
council of trustees and alumni in 2015
showed that half of americans can't say
when the civil war was fought
in science the pew study finds that just
39 of americans have a high level of
scientific knowledge
with 29 having little knowledge
everybody else falling somewhere
in the mediocre middle which is probably
where i fall to be honest with you but i
went to public school so i'm exhibit
eight
the media likes to trumpet headlines
like like these they like these kinds of
headlines
showing that americans are stupid and
ignorant but they don't like to connect
and
to connect the dots and draw the obvious
conclusions
our education system is an abysmal
failure
if you think that americans are ignorant
and stupid then what does that tell you
about the system that's supposed to be
educating these people
ours is an education system that
produces citizens who cannot pass a
citizenship test
what more needs to be said of course we
must stipulate
that the education system has failed to
do what it should be trying to do
which is to equip new generations with
the strong base of knowledge and
critical thinking skills
they'll need to be well-rounded
well-adjusted contributing members of
society
it has not failed to do what it what it
is
actually tried to do which is to
indoctrinate new generations into the
religion of leftism
the rioters terrorizing our cities
screaming about the imaginary boogeyman
of systemic racism
illustrate at once both sides of this
dichotomy
the fact is that you know there was
never any hope of reclaiming the culture
defeating leftism or anything else so
long as nearly everyone
sends their kids to government
indoctrination centers for six hours a
day five days a week nine months a year
for the majority of their first 18 years
of life
worse we send our kids to these places
fully aware
that they will be learning a lot more
than the abcs and 123s
the education that they get will stretch
far beyond
basic academic subjects they will be
shaped informed and molded
intellectually spiritually
psychologically morally
by the government school system and
worst of all
many parents even conservative parents
have wanted that
i can't tell you how many times i've had
conversations with parents
defending the public school system by
saying things like i need my kids to be
socialized
really you want the government to
socialize your child
that's what you want that's a job you
trust the government to do
you don't trust it with health care or
your tax money or anything else but you
trust it with your child's heart and
mind
and you trust that it will socialize
your child in a way that's best for him
as long as we have this mentality
there's no hope for the culture there's
no hope for conservatism
but i sense that maybe that mentality is
finally starting to shift
a glimmer of hope shines through
so it comes down to this public schools
simply do not deserve the faith we have
had in them
nor have they earned the credit we have
often given them
they also do not deserve to be seen as
inevitable or necessary
and the school system itself has now
admitted as much
by shutting down suddenly for months on
end even protesting to ensure that it
can remain shut for longer
insisting that it's not an essential
service like walmart or the local liquor
store
the school system has let the truth slip
we don't actually need it
society can function without it there is
nothing it is doing that can't be done
at home
parents are discovering this too they're
trying their hand at educating their own
children
which is something they were already
doing and all parents already do whether
in official capacity or not
and many are discovering that it's not
so hard as they thought
we could just hope that more parents
have this revelation that the government
school system is rendered finally
obsolete and superfluous that would be
one good thing one extremely good thing
to come out of this
godforsaken year let's get to our five
headlines
[Music]
you know if you have credit card debt
you got to take care of it as soon as
possible
because it's gonna it's hurting your
credit every minute that it's there
it's making your life harder and light
stream that's why i'll tell you about
light stream light streams fixed rate
credit
credit card consolidation loan starts at
5.95
apr with auto pay and excellent credit
um and it's lower than the average
credit card interest rate of
over 19 apr you can get a loan from
uh 5 000 to 100 100 000 with absolutely
no
fees and the application is 100 online
and very easy to go through
you can even get your money and as soon
as a day if you you know the day you
apply you can get that very same day
lightstream believes that people with
good credit
deserve a great interest rate and no
fees
and that's exactly what they deliver and
uh you know the thing is you
don't take it for me they'll take it
from don't take it from any ad you hear
take it from the people people love
lightstream here's what this customer
had to say
i heard about lightstream on a podcast
that was able to look on the website and
get clear information
the application process was quick and
easy um
you know i i've i i've seen we've all
seen this there are many people who have
debt they have credit card debt
other kinds of debt and it prevents them
from
moving on with their lives moving up in
their careers uh there's so much that
you want to do where that's going to
interfere and that's why you need
live stream my listeners can save even
more with an additional interest rate
discount the only way to get this
discount is to go to lightstream.com
walsh l-i-g-h-t-s-t-r-e-a-m-com
walsh subject to credit approval rate
includes 0.5
auto pay discount terms and conditions
apply and offers are subject to change
without notice visit lightstream.com
walsh for more information
okay a bunch of headlines in fact this
one i don't even have here so
i think we'll talk about this tomorrow
more but i just right before we went on
the air
saw the story out of nashville about the
nashville mayor's office
according to report uh emails were
leaked
showing that um they were trying to hide
the fact
that uh there were very few coronavirus
cases coming out of
uh restaurants and bars they'd shut down
the restaurants and bars and then
in the in the emails exchanges they were
some people in the mayor's office were
worried
that more people weren't getting sick
because of the restaurants and bars
which means that they can't justify
shutting it down this is and it makes
you wonder like
how many other cities was this happening
where the people in positions of power
shutting down businesses and knew
because they had the data they knew
that there was no reason for it that
that the data didn't support it but they
suppressed that data and didn't tell the
public about it how many i'm thinking
probably many cities where this happened
so think about democrat mayors for a
second
um democrat mayors okay shut down their
economies
on bad or phony data and then after
months of that
in many of these cities allowed
rampaging mobs to run through the street
burning and looting at will
you have to be a masochist at this point
to vote for one of these lunatics to run
your city
this is beyond politics if you're just a
normal person especially if you're a
business owner or you have a family
why would you want i don't care how you
feel about republicans or trump or
anyone else
why would you want one of these people
ron look at what they're doing
uh but we'll talk more about that
tomorrow this is just a huge scandal
this story
so i want to dive more into it but okay
we start here here are um
here are several headlines all about
attorney general bill barr
and these are supposed to make us hate
him i guess and think that he's scary
and mean so from the guardian bill barr
reportedly suggested bringing sedition
charges against protesters
from cnn bill barr says calls for
coronavirus lockdowns are the greatest
intrusion on civil liberties other than
slavery in u.s history
and then from the from the hill barr
asked prosecutors to explore
charging seattle mayor over protest zone
these are all headlines in like the last
day about bill barr so the media wants
us to to read that it's al what a
terrible guy
but of course i have the exact opposite
reaction i think that's
awesome that's yes thank you see the
media
thinks all of that makes him look bad
but because they don't understand normal
people to normal people we read that and
we think well yeah
chronovirus locked down to the greatest
threat to civil liberty well that's not
exactly true and
it's only the only reason that's not
true is because of abortion abortion
is the greatest threat to civil liberty
um
since slavery but this is definitely in
the top five
and then he wanted to bring sedition
charges against insurrectionists who are
burning government buildings with the
stated goal of overthrowing the
government yeah
that's what sedition is absolutely and
then bill barr wants to charge a mayor
with crimes
because she refused to enforce the law
and put her citizens
in jeopardy because of it again yes this
is what normal people believe the media
is disgusted by confused by horrified by
the sorts of things that normal people
think and believe
uh number two cdc director robert
redfield
not be not to be confused with robert
redford
when you see this guy i'm sure you won't
confuse them uh he was testifying before
congress yesterday
and had this to say about when we can
return to
regular life listen tell me when when
you think we'll have
a vaccine as best you can
ready to to administer to the public
doctor anthony well i think as uh dr
cadillac
said i think there will be vaccine that
initially be available
sometime between november and december
but very limited supply and will have to
be prioritized if you're asking me when
is it going to be generally available to
the american public
so we can begin to take advantage of
vaccine
to get back to our regular life i think
we're probably looking at third late
second quarter third quarter
2021 and so you think by the late second
and third or third quarter
we will have started to to vaccinate
people
i think the vaccination will begin in
november december
and then we'll pick up you know and
it'll be in a prioritized way those
first responders and those at greatest
risk for death
and then eventually that will expand you
know there's about
it's hard to believe but there's about
80 million people in our country
that have significant comorbidities that
put themselves at risk
right they have to get vaccinated and
then the general public
okay third quarter of 2021.
now personally i've been living my
regular life all throughout this i never
stopped living my regular life
uh but if you actually are planning to
remain hiding in your closet or under
your bed
for the next year or more uh then i i i
don't know what to say to you
um remember though 15 days to slow the
spread
i guess 15 days you know that's
that's kind of like uh maybe days it's
kind of like the word
mostly now we hear mostly peaceful when
the media says that so these are these
are these are words that can be
uh interpreted in very broad sense
or maybe you know there's the maybe
we're talking about days in a biblical
sense here
they said 15 days maybe they meant it
you know there's the debate in genesis
we talk about
was it seven days of creation uh or was
it was was each day representative of
billions of years
and so maybe when we heard 15 days to
slow the spread they meant it in the
biblical way that each day is a billion
years i don't know
um redfield also had this to say about
masks listen
i'm not going to comment directly about
the president but i am going to comment
as the cdc director that
face masks these face men are the most
important powerful public health tool we
have
and i will continue to appeal for all
americans
all individuals in our country to
embrace these phase coverings i've said
it if we did it
for six eight ten twelve weeks we'd
bring this pandemic
uh under control these actually we have
clear scientific evidence
they work and they are our best defense
i might even go so far as to say that
this face mask
is more guaranteed to protect me
against covid that when i take a covet
vaccine
because the immunogenicity may be
70 percent and if i don't get an immune
response the vaccine is not going to
protect me this face mask will
so i do want to keep asking the american
public to take the responsibility
particularly the 18
to 25 year olds where we're seeing the
outbreak in america continue to go like
this
because we haven't got the acceptance
the personal responsibility that we need
for all americans to embrace this face
mask
okay masks are more protective than
vaccines that's what he's saying now
now let's rewind the clock back six
months
and take a listen to what he said about
masks back then
should you wear a mask if you're healthy
no
okay so there he says he's asked if
you're healthy should you wear a mask
six months ago he said no period so we
went from
and think about what the surgeon general
said six months ago five or six months
ago
screaming at us don't wear a mask stop
wearing a mask
so we went from stop wearing masks you
dumb hicks
to masks are more protective than
vaccines
in six months and the excuse is
well we're still we're still discovering
you know we're still figuring out the
science of it
people have been using masks in a
medical context for centuries
you still are figuring out the science
and
our understanding of the science of mass
has evolved that much in a few months
really
no whatever however effective masks are
or aren't they've known it all along but
they've given us two different answers
and so you wonder why people are a
little bit skeptical of the mask thing
number three here's nancy pelosi on
msnbc yesterday with a very stark and
sudden
emotional pivot watch this
climate crisis which is causing these uh
has has an impact
has a uh has influenced what is
happening
in california and the whole west as well
as the storms that are
uh battering the gulf coast
this is a reality so and when it comes
to the chronovirus
they have contempt for science that's
why we are almost 200 000 people
who will lose their lives by the end of
this week
200 000 people and that's why
that their contempt for science as to
what the
uh the climate crisis is yeah i think
old nancy's acting is getting getting a
little rusty there
she needs to run through those lines
about 10 or 15 more times before going
live with it
this is what happens when you miss dress
rehearsals you know you got to be yeah
it's
practice makes perfect this just shows
that politicians you know
when they've been in office for a while
they really forget how to be human
and that's not even a joke i really
believe that i think that that's why we
need term limits
they can't relate to human emotions
anymore because they've they lose a
little piece of their humanity with each
year they spend in that environment
so by that by the time they get to
pelosi's age uh they're like
you know spock or something but not as
smart
dumb spocks is that's that's who's
running the country
no brain no soul when they attempt to
imitate human emotion it comes off as as
you know
like awkward and sort of grotesque often
more towards grotesque i think
watching pelosi imitate human emotions
it's it's kind of like
uh you know what it's like it's like i
don't know if you've ever seen men in
black
um there's that in men in black the
first one there's that
alien bug creature that steals a guy's
skin
and wears it around that's who nancy
pelosi reminds me of
no offense to her intended of course i
mean it has a compliment number four
from the daily wire
um the pizza chain where a kid can be a
kid is now looking to destroy
seven billion of its famous prize
tickets after filing for bankruptcy this
past summer due to the steep drop in
business during the covet 19 pandemic
according to the new york post chuck e
cheese parent company cec entertainment
said in a court filing on monday
that the heavy supply of prize tickets
are no longer needed
the tickets are valued at 9 billion or
sorry
9 million it's not 9 billion it's 7
billion tickets
valued at nine million dollars that's
what they're destroying okay so seven
billion prize tickets
if i remember correctly at the price
counter with that many tickets you could
have redeemed all of that
for a chinese finger trap a yo-yo and
three jolly ranchers
it took a lot is what i'm trying to say
at those prize counters
uh you know you go up to the prize
counter you've got just like a whole
bucket of tickets and you're so excited
you're like
daddy what can i get and he says oh well
you can get this
little finger puppet um five
finally you may have heard the big news
that daily wire is leaving
los angeles and moving to nashville uh
why are we leaving los angeles well
because la is a crumbling cesspit
and it's currently on fire at the moment
so i say we but i never lived here
um i will however be moving to nashville
with the crew
finally leaving the shack in the
wilderness that i've been living in
we're going to find a new shack in the
wilderness in nashville
or in tennessee somewhere um i will of
course be bringing my banjo
it is nashville after all my banjo which
you can see in this studio here
this studio you know sort of a preview
of things to come maybe i'll have a real
studio
um this is this is all very new for me
because i've always done the show just
by myself
in my little hole somewhere even right
now i mean there are people in the room
right now
in the dark staring at me and it's a
very strange it's very strange
experience
but it's going to be very exciting for
for us
apparently not everyone is happy that
we're coming though
here's an article on a website called
the nashville scene
headline is poll moving to town
ben shapiro announced he and the daily
wire are coming to nashville thanks we
hate it
then the article says there's nothing
clever to say here clearly
ben shapiro is a proudly obtuse bigot
who rose rapidly through the ranks of
conservative media because he was a
young person who appeared to have read a
book or two and hated popular culture
now he and his right wing facebook
content generator the daily wire are
moving here
and then it goes on and on about how ben
is an a-hole and a horrible guy
and he's moving to nashville etc
um and i read this article and i have to
say i'm really upset and offended by it
i think it's totally out of line
completely uncalled for
because i also am an a-hole
and i also am moving to town and i don't
even get any mention here at all
i have been erased otherwised my
existence has been delegitimized by this
i haven't worked so hard to cultivate my
a-whole brand to be ignored in this way
it only goes to show you know my people
my community of a-holes
have so much further to go before we are
really appreciated
and respected for our contributions to
society
so we'll be in uh nashville soon and
we're looking forward to that
are we getting into our daily
cancellation in just a second but before
we do
um you know i uh
i have to admit i'm sort of a high
maintenance guy not not in
not in most faces of life i don't think
but with sleeping i am
i have a very particular i have very
particular needs when i'm sleeping
and if those needs are met then i can
sleep like a baby if they're not then
i'm tossing and turning and whining all
night and annoying my wife
um and that's why i'm so happy that uh
that i have
like so many millions of others
discovered my pillow uh look if you
if you want to get a good night's rest
even if you're not super high
maintenance like me when it comes to
sleeping
you need to have a comfortable bed
comfortable sheets a nice pillow these
are the things that you need
and that's why you need my pillow mike
lindell is the inventor of my pillow
mike's latest deal
is on his giza dream sheets which are
made from the world's best cotton
giza cotton they're very soft breathable
extreme
extremely durable i can attest to all of
this right now the giza dream sheets are
at a at a two for one low price
plus free shipping with promo code daily
wire
all of the my pillow products come with
a 60 day money back guarantee
if you don't like it but i guarantee you
will like it uh i could say you know i'm
traveling right now and uh and so i
don't have
my my pillow because i can't i just
can't bring myself to be one of those
guys that brings a pillow on the plane
um so i left it at home my wife is
enjoying it and now i have some
crappy hotel pillow and i am suffering
immensely because of it and i can't wait
to get home for many reasons
out of los angeles but mainly because of
my pillow just go to mypillow.com click
on the radio listeners square to check
out
the two for one low price on the giza
dream sheets plus free shipping
there are also deep discounts on all
other my pillow products enter promo
code
daily wire or call 800-651-1148 for
these great
radio specials all right let's get to
our daily cancellation
uh today i will be canceling cardinal
tobin
of newark new jersey this is the second
day in a row that i'm canceling a priest
this time of cardinal
tomorrow it will be the pope as i work
my way up the ranks and find many
cancelable candidates along the way
unfortunately uh it's not my fault you
must understand
i don't decide who i'm going to cancel
the universe makes this decision for me
cardinal tobin today is getting canceled
for some remarks he made during an
online panel discussion a few days ago
this is what he said listen i think that
a person in good conscience
could vote for mr biden
i frankly in my in my own way of
thinking have
a more difficult time with the other
option now he later clarified
that he's not endorsing any candidate
but he is saying that a person a
catholic christian
can in good conscience vote for the
candidate who supports
murdering babies in the womb now let's
back up here for a moment okay a little
bit of a
of background on the most esteemed
cardinal tobin
a couple years ago it was reported by
the american spectator that cardinal
tobin
was having an italian actor and model
staying in his rectory
now here's that actor you can see his
instagram pictures here i've been told i
look a lot like this guy
i pose like him too when i do photo
photo shoots
actually that's not true i did a photo
shoot yesterday here yesterday and it
was it was absolutely awful
uh i'm the most awkward person as you
have probably noticed anyway
that guy was staying uh with the
cardinal in his
record tobin when confronted about this
said that the guy uh francesco
castiglione
is his name was was staying there
because he was he was taking language
classes at seton hall
now why would an italian actor and model
who likes to take shirtless photos stay
at a cardinals directory so he could
take language classes
at another place well your guess is as
good as mine
but use your imagination or don't use it
if you're about to eat lunch
here's another interesting tidbit around
the same time
that this francesco chap was staying at
his rectory
tobin tweeted this one night this is a
tweet that he sent out a couple years
ago it said
supposed to be airborne in 10 minutes
nighty night baby i love you
now obviously this was not meant to be
tweeted it seems he meant to send that
as a text message to someone
but to who is the question he's a
cardinal he's supposed to be chaste and
celibate
who is he texting nighty night baby to
now when asked about this he said that
it was meant to go to his sister
yes his sister now i have four sisters
myself
i can tell you i i would never say
nighty night baby
i love you to any of them in any context
because that would be enormously creepy
and weird does tobin just have a very
very close relationship with the sisters
or was that meant to go to someone else
entirely
who knows but it does raise some
interesting questions about the cardinal
um and then this happens so
can a person in good conscience vote for
joe biden they certainly cannot text
nighty night baby to their sister in
good conscience or to anyone else by the
way if you're a man
there's really no context where that's
appropriate as for biden who seems like
the kind of guy who has texted that to
many people in his life
um the answer is no you cannot support
him joe biden supports
abortion on demand he supports abortion
at every stage
of pregnancy he supports federal funds
paying for abortion
the other person on the ticket kamela
harris is even more radically
pro-infanticide
she actually prosecuted pro-life
undercover journalists in california for
investigating planned parenthood planned
parenthood by the way
at the time was also a big camala harris
donor
nothing wrong with that right uh
investigating the people
or or or trying to criminally prosecute
the people who are investigating
one of your big donors no corruption
there at all
remember that the democrat party at this
point fully endorses abortions
all abortions at all stages of
development it supports and wants to
actively facilitate and fund
late term abortion that would be
abortion of babies who are past the
point of viability babies
infants who can survive outside the womb
babies that look
just like any newborn infant you've ever
seen
these procedures let me and this gets a
little graphic here i apologize for it
but this but
we all need to know this this is what
joe biden supports
uh late term abortions they are
performed by
injecting the fully developed infant
child with poison
usually into his skull while he's still
in the womb if he dies from the poison
the mother will carry her dead child
around inside her for two or three days
before eventually delivering the dead
child either at the clinic or into a
toilet
in her hotel or her house as very often
happens
but sometimes the baby doesn't die from
the first injection and instead lives in
pain and agony for those three days
remember this is a fully developed baby
fully developed nervous system it feels
everything
so three to two or three days of being
poisoned um eventually the child will
then be injected again
and then removed from the womb piece by
piece
ripped apart by forceps
as he is extracted from his mother's
body
this is what we do in this country this
is how we treat our children
and this is what the democrat party and
joe biden support
this is what cardinal tobin says you can
support
by supporting candidates who will
facilitate and fund this kind of
barbarity
by the way you'll be told that the late
term abortion procedure i just described
represents only
one percent of all abortions well
let's just say that's true there are
a million abortions a year in this
country that means ten
thousand fully developed infant children
are poisoned and then ripped apart limb
from limb
every year ten thousand
how many children do you think die in
school shootings every year it's not ten
thousand i can tell you that
it's barely a fraction of ten thousand
now how do you think the left would
react
if you said that school shootings aren't
a big deal because only a handful of
kids fall victim to them
each year i mean what's the perce of all
the of all the children who go to school
what's the percentage that die in school
shootings
it ain't one percent i can tell you that
it's point zero zero whatever one
percent
um and this is in
but one percent we're told in this
context
doesn't matter but here we're just
talking about late term abortion which
the biden harris ticket endorses
all abortions of course are barbaric
murderous evil
a christian cannot support this no
decent person of any religion or
non-religion can support this
now donald trump may have a difficult
personality
he may say things that offend you but
presidential elections are not
personality contests
rather they are not supposed to be
personality context contests they are
but they shouldn't be
if you vote for the man whose
personality you most relate to you're a
fool
and you shouldn't even have the right to
vote if you're that stupid
what matters is what these people will
actually do
and we know that joe biden among many
other troubling things will take
active steps to ensure that more babies
are murdered
a christian who votes for that is
committing a grave sin
and cardinal tobin committed a grave sin
by encouraging it
so cardinal tobin is cancelled and
that'll do it for today everyone thanks
for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
president trump beats joe biden for the
first time in a major poll democrats get
foreign policy
wrong again and more evidence of voter
fraud creeps up in new jersey check it
out on the michael knowles show